حبيبه مرزوق تخطف الانظار في اداء مذهل
سيلفي لمحمد صلاح يشعل الجدل حول الاثار
المصريه المنهوبه تركي ال الشيخ يعلق على
مجامله محمد الحلو للسعوديه والعراق يفقد
اثنين من اشهر اصواته اليكم الابرز في
اسبوع
[موسيقى]
لافتات لاعبه الجمباز حبيبه مرزوق
والملقبه بالفراشه المصريه الانظار في حفل
ختام بطوله العالم للجمباز في مدريد
باسبانيا بعرض مستوحى من الحضاره المصريه
حقق تفاعلا واسعا على منصات التواصل في
مصر وعبر وزير الشباب والرياضه المصري
اشرف صبحي عن سعادته بما وصفه بالاداء
المذهل لحبيبه وذلك خلال استقباله لها
كما حظيت صور نجم الكره المصريه ونادي
ليفربول الانجليزي محمد صلاح من امام
مجموعه قطع اثريه مصريه يعرضها المتحف
البريطاني بتفاعل واسع ايضا في مصر واعادت
جدل ضروره المطالبه باسترداد ما وصف
بالاثار المصريه المسروقه ومنها تمثال
الملك رمسيس الثاني الذي التقط صلاح صوره
سيلفي امامه
[موسيقى]
وبعد جدل مجامله محمد الحلو للسعوديه في
حفل كاسيت 90 اهدى المطرب المصري اغنيه
خاصه لاهل المملكه خلال الحفل الجماهيري
الذي احياه الاسبوع الماضي ضمن فعاليات
تقويم جدا وقدم فيه مجموعه من اجمل اغاني
[موسيقى]
وشكر تركي ال الشيخ المطرب المصري محمد
الحلو على اغنيته في اتصال مباشر خلال
الحفل علق فيه على جدل عمار يا سعوديه
وعماره مصر وعماره
[تصفيق]
حياتك وبعد تالقه مؤخرا في ليله الدموع
بجده صدم جمهور المطرب المصري احمد سعد
باعلان مصممه الازياء علياء بسيوني
انفصالها عنه برغبه منه بحسب قولها وسط
ظروف عائليه صعبه تمر بها حاليا ووجهت له
كلاما لاذعا لم يعلق عليه حتى تاريخه
ونختتم الابرز بوداع بغداد لواحد من اشهر
قامات الغناء العراقي ياس خضر الذي فارق
الحياه عن عمري 85 عاما كما فقد العراق
الشاعر الغنائي الكبير كريم العراقي عن
عمر 68 عاما وفي سوريا اعلن عن وفاه امين
الخياط عازف القانون والملحن والمايسترو
الشهير والذي كان ايضا نقيبا للفنانين
السوريين مطلع السبعينيات وفارق الحياه عن
عمري 87 عاما